une bataille de pince pour ramasser un
mégot de cigarette
pas de doute les enfants se sont pris au
jeu du ramassage de déchets une façon
ludique pour ce père de famille de
sensibiliser ses enfants de 8 et 12 ans
son respect de l'environnement
tu vois là le papier l'arc là ça aussi
ça fait partie des choses qu'on ramasse
et pas que dans l'herbe en fait c'est la
ville dans sa globalité des petits
objets du quotidien retrouver dans la
nature ton temps particulièrement
présents comme petites choses n'empêche
que tu as vu en les cigarettes sans
présente au gros de la pollution pour
l'instant en ville en te voir tout ce
qui est je t'ai je pense que ça va aussi
l'essentiel vis-à-vis de leurs copains
et peut-être les amener à dire leurs
copains de pasht et parterres plaisir en
transition a pensé à tout pour permettre
la récolte au mieux sans oublier le tri
des déchets la chariotte elle permet de
délester un peu les personnes qui
ramasse et de faire du tri bas
directement c'est à dire le vert le
carton et les ordures ménagères de
manière un peu plus facile
sensibilisation réussi chez les plus
jeunes qui se confronte directement à la
quantité de déchets retrouvés hors des
poubelles
le nombre de déclics et à par terre et
les noms de cigarettes
c'est c'est plutôt énorme déjà devant
chez moi y'en a plein du coup ça
prononce un mineur et un peu oui je suis
sensible et ça m'énerve vraiment les
airs en transition renouvellera l'action
régulièrement prochain rendez vous dans
les rues de la commune fin octobre